les doigts certains se rappelleront du
populaire colonel centers et de son
poulet frit kentucky dans les années 70
succès planétaire
même les japonais l'adorent au point
encore aujourd'hui d'en réserver pour
les repas des fêtes
mais le colonel sanders n'a rien inventé
partout dans le monde le poulet frit et
très populaire et il s'apprête de
plusieurs façons incursion aujourd'hui
en corée et en haïti le prix free m à
une place je dirais très importante dans
la cuisine haïtienne vous dirais même si
la sq pondérant c'est la première place
mais l'additionnel mans le poulet est
fait de deux façons free à l'huile
normal puis free panos la panure elle
même elle est constituée de quoi donc la
pagnol un mélange la farine d'usure
dépendamment de la personne est de 3,1
ghz en pologne avant d'offrir le poulet
le chef chupa aura fait mariner les
pièces 24 heures on prépare des états
comme des oignons les poivrons rouges
font rage online puis on mettre d'autres
épices du chef
la variante qu'on amène au poulet frit
ben c'est que notre chef ne cherche pas
une fois que ces sorties de lille puis
green sourcils 32 dents puis ça fait du
poulet frit genre
mixez barbichu
je crois le fric aurait déjà beaucoup du
savoir comme épicé par des pc et pc
mais le soleil nous avons beaucoup de ça
va chez les coréens
on passe par les sauces pour offrir une
variété de saveurs pas d'assez crise de
pelé avait beau y soit le profit à côté
sonia d'autres à notre sens fait maison
le poulet pané légèrement avant d'être
passé deux fois à la friteuse conflit
plaît toutefois pas ce que l on vous en
doute le porter en plus un costume à
l'extérieur christian elling tellier jeu
du buteur
on offre également le poulet frit en
sandwich on appelle bao de celui qui est
le plus absolu ou au vélo loisirs se
relever c'est un petit peu sucré oh oui
là le feu arrive tranquillement encore
et vous mangerez picard très piquant
pouvait plus de piquant plus que ça même
jour avec avec la bière avec la barre
comment s'appelait salles le 5 à 7 et
jean est fini mais samedi le peuple est
avec la bière comme chip au check-in
play meet you samedi la pierre la valeur
est très fine
christian est à l'étude
à l'intérieur c'est plaisant ce cas
fréquent même principe que beaucoup de
saveurs différentes beaucoup de sava
différents et tous les sens
telle maison comment dit-on que c'est
bon un corps était le 6e samedi magie
magie ta machine à magenta de machine à
machine ait beaucoup de plats qu'on
appelle pas étudiants ou les baby que
s'il vous plaît les poulets sont
toujours non toujours marine et ensuite
s'ils ont décliné soit free avec une
panure ou pas de panure ou free et avec
la sauce puis cette source là les pics
en toile et popi quand les papilles
quand c'est vraiment une chose barbecue
c'est excellent le poulet frit mais pape
année c'est exercer sa très bon c'est le
plus
13-10 est bon parce que c'est qu'au
soutien mais s'y empilent certaine
poésie
j'étudie campo j'adore le nom c'est
vraiment une femme est ce que ça a une
signification particulière oui parce
qu'en période quand vous lancez une
devinette petites criques et les gens
répondent craque
voilà c'est ça il a team en faire des
villes d'ici là deux mineurs c'est quoi
ces deux ministres en exactement ça